so i you have to
uh keep the guy in check okay so
right right here you have his body
you're just you're moving his body
moving his body going to the
direction of behind him
from the blind spot
blind spot okay
don't lengthen his arms because you're
going to feel his weight again
right there right there this is where
all the choreography kids
let you do it
it's not going to happen so if you watch
his arm
this check that i have on his elbow and
the connection
go back here i'm going to leave it
boom i never give it back i never touch
i never give it back stays there
check i reverse the chest you're in
and think of this opening as
precisely that you want his body
this
[Music]
all right here his elbow is in the way
of my entry
so i'm going to move it and go in
okay let's try in the middle of your
moon
if your dojo is the heart in the back
if you pay attention and that heart
is this mixture of the inward spiral
and the outward spot
[Music]
and that is what you're doing in this
technique okay
so you start at the bottom of the heart
i'm at the bottom of the heart
okay and i'm moving i go to the line
spot
and i will come in and i have the top of
the heart
so let's simplify it without all the
steps
so this is a weird looking heart
you see this is a weird looking
part
[Music]
so
it's not two moves
can't go here no two moves
it's one move
so uh this move
this is okay
that is not marshall your your goal
is to attack his body you want to fight
him not his
limbs and you don't want to be group
dependent
i come like this go ahead and grab
please
i cannot do this i cannot do that
i'm coming in attacking his balance
and the movement the movement will
eventually disarm his grip
do you see it's off that's when i should
clap
[Music]
that would be ikea coming over here
that's all that is okay
i might be near it but i'm not grabbing
it
till it's off of me it comes in my hand
on its own
watch this hat
pay attention to when i close it it's
the last part of the technique
this is you up you see you're
waiting there
you're not attacking his body
and you're dreaming this 2k just let go
for you
try it again so again the order is body
body using body first
and body throughout so it goes
body full elbow
the techniques are redundant if
something doesn't happen until i have
the last
piece you're not doing the technique
right
so if if i can't manipulate his body
till i get his wrist then it's not
i'm not doing it's not partially viable
so body boom elbow goes around you don't
need the wrist because it's the last
redundant puzzle piece
let's go no wrist hands